[Music]
how's everyone doing on this wonderful
Wednesday
are you listening on Wednesday hope you
are if not that's fine welcome to
another episode of files or so how are
you I'm good how are you I am delightful
what a great episode I'm excited about
this one I feel like it's one of those
long time comings I'm a you know most of
my life is is getting on the wrong side
of people and then wanting to be on the
right side and sometimes with social
media and people judging to opinions and
expectations and then we and then we
mean and we become fast friends that is
the story after the episode what did
they think about you before well they
just they hated me like hated my
understanding is they were not fond of
me and bachelor nation okay and and they
are the wonderful women of the morning
toast very very funny very funny I was
dying laughing Claudia Jack yeah Jackie
Oh Jackie but yes I mean I'll and there
was this show with Rachel that kind of
opened the doors of peace and harmony
turned into fast friends then they were
out in LA recording using our studios
yeah our studio no we were happy to have
them and they came on the show and we
just had a lot of fun yeah Claudia
opened up about some stuff I was kind of
surprised by yeah and I hope you really
enjoy it embark I'm getting tagged by
some of our listeners with their embark
purchase and the dog next and they seem
to be really thrilled again I've said
this before this is the most fascinating
thing I've ever seen out there it's a
dog DNA or DNA kit people love their
dogs in retro so and yes know so much so
little information about the dog yeah
now you can know everything you possibly
need to know about your dog its history
yeah its health yes you can be proactive
than reactive you can know exactly what
kind of breed they are you don't have to
guess anymore I think there this I think
they're right and our producer did this
on his dog and found out that she was
100% like you know it's great to make
you a pup
yes rescue your dogs but like also when
you do you you have less history on that
dog exactly and it's good to know for a
variety of reasons and embark will help
you do that
also maybe if you like share a dog with
a couple this is a fun gift to get your
significant other like amazing game yes
meaningful there's no way anyone's not
gonna be like what an amazing gift and
as we always talk about what a wonderful
talking point on a date the funniest
thing is that our producer keeps getting
emails about his dog's relatives they're
keep finding new relatives that make
sense you're embarking you're gonna want
to have it if you have a pup you need to
have them bark and bark has an exclusive
holiday offer you can't get anywhere
else go to em bark vet calm now and use
promo code VI al to save 15% off your
dog DNA test kit visit embark vet calm
and use promo code VI al l to save best
fiends colorful wonderful graphics
result what level you want I'm opening
it right now I just Ottoman times I feel
stressed I go on best fiends and it
makes me feel relaxed it's the funnest
phone game you can download for free
it's a you're not what your your your
bet I'm not good at it but I love it
it's easy I am on level 400 don't you
know that does not just discourage me
from constantly playing it it's so but
it's okay look at that screen look at it
you have it up I haven't and there's a
it's Halloween themed right now which is
fun you have to collect the candy corns
look you can hear her passion we're
trying to do a pocket playing best
fiends and as we say engage your brain
with fun puzzles and collect tons of
cute
characters and that's what I love most
about it is that you engage your brain
mm-hmm it is an exercise of your mental
capacity five-star rated mobile puzzle
game with over 100 million downloads
globally download free on the Apple App
Store or Google Play
that's best friends without the are best
fiends hey Halloween's tomorrow
Halloween is tomorrow I uh we record
this obviously a few days before I'm
gonna go to a Halloween party this week
and I will have gone to it yes do you
know you're gonna be I think I'm gonna
go as a pilot a pilot you know because
like a stripper pilot no more like a guy
who might be the bachelor Oh God really
listen it's a it's low-hanging fruit
it's also a very easy gift I mean I
costume to do yeah I guy win on Amazon I
bought like the pilot wait you already
bought it
yeah it should show up today we'll see
how it turns out I did you tell that
you're gonna he's off the grid right now
oh right I've been told that we kind of
have a similar resemblance and I'm
wondering if I styled my hair like Pete
a trimmer but he's got some facial hair
going on the show he's he's filming do
you see some pics of him growing a
little bit of a beer let's see if the
Pete the pilot costume works okay it's
low-hanging fruit do you think I need a
rose oh god I'm just shocked do you want
to do this usually you want to distance
yourself from the bachelor true but this
is like kind of fun and the party I'm
going to I feel like it might be a bit
of a hit maybe you just need a windmill
something windmill to add on ooh there
you go or you could just keep asking
women to come back to your Oh what about
a band-aid I heard that but yeah a
band-aid on my on my for definitely need
to be a day probably I'm curious if I do
it right I feel like perform well in
Instagram is it Delta or is it just you
works for Delta but the ID the pen yeah
generic no but me what party you're
going to uh it's just a party this party
doesn't my profile
high-powered Halloween party I'm going
as a squirrel I always go as a squirrel
because I always babysit on Halloween
and it's actually really [ __ ] a
onesie it's the tail inflates it's like
actually really good costume have you
ever done the sexy costume no never and
I have tried to flirt in the squirrel
God ship and got nowhere
really I find it be really charming when
a when a woman dress not sexy right
don't get me wrong I will certainly draw
my eyes to the hot nurse but I'm very
attracted and intrigued more importantly
intrigued by the the not sexy caution
well no one else at the party last year
felt like you I mean it's hard to like
you know want to hit on the the witch
that really went all out to look like
say the Wicked Witch of the West because
like I don't know what you actually look
like and you actually look scary but
it's like the the cute squirrel yeah if
you go cute rather than sexy mm-hmm I
think that I'm intrigued
okay I mean I will I will I will notice
you at a party more than I will notice
the the sexy nurse just just a thought
so if you're going to a Halloween party
tomorrow maybe call inaudible inaudible
that's a football term I'm sorry you uh
change the play at the line of scrimmage
at the last minute given what the
defense shows you and then you have an
alternative thing that might perform
better than you had originally thought
inaudible yeah I'm kind of over the what
you know the sexy costume is the girl
you want to take home but not take to
mom so to speak we're looking for
Halloween I mean hey I don't know well
let's get to it the morning toast women
fun episode for all you toasters tuning
in as I know I'm sure you are and what a
dedicated fan base come back and check
us out yeah you know I say this too
sometimes we do episodes for people I
know you're tuning in for our guests and
I appreciate
you doing that yeah it's like the priest
or Sunday at Catholic Mass went yeah I
grew up Catholic yeah
come back other Sundays during the year
we're doing some great things check us
out on Monday as we do a lot of dating
and relations people we don't talk as
fast as them do they talk fast
you didn't notice that I feel like they
talk so fast easy now
toasters are very in a good way like I'm
like always on my toes alright dusters
are very protective I know they're their
hosts it's a great episode I really I
really enjoyed hanging out with both
Claudia and Jackie I hope you guys enjoy
it too and wait no longer
good morning toast toast on the fire but
on bum toast on the file toast on the
file Hey toast on the fire is great this
is hard we try to do this all in the
very beginning without any practice I
really appreciate it
count like when your pitch is so perfect
like you just want to put only the best
stuff out there I'm ashamed to have been
a part of that I'm not gonna lie I just
appreciate the effort
everyone Claudia and Jackie good morning
toes Wow
what up lapis are on my podcast on our
podcast so many times we are honored to
be here and I am honored to have you it
is not without asking you guys to come
so just it's not as if we would have a
study a matter of us being in LA right
now we're never here we're not shy we
would have asked thanks for coming
ladies I know we've talked a lot about
on your show about the journey that
we've all come to it all really did
start on this podcast with in this room
in this room with with with Rachel
Lindsey oh yes love her
who brought you guys up and and and gave
you guys a lot of props and I just kind
of meekly it was like huh when we heard
I think they liked it like we had a pit
in our stomach that dropped when you
started to talk about us we're like oh
now he's finally gonna lay into us after
all the things we thought
and you were so mature about it and I
was like damn how could we hate someone
like that who's obviously so kind and
mature and like not petty not petty like
us like you had the opportunity to slap
us and had every reason to and you
didn't and like we learned so much in
that minute is so true like truly like
you don't always have to say something
nasty about someone Nick Vile's didn't
really great guy and then few things we
learned you know and then what you would
think about someone you watch on TV is
not how they actually are so like just
based on what we knew about you from
being The Bachelor in quote-unquote
being the villain like you would have
responded in a negative way but you
didn't so it's like maybe maybe he's not
what he seems like on on ABC or option
for you don't know what we said about
you wait or option five you have no idea
who we are
option four I don't know most of what
you said it's only only assume I'm not
yeah
I don't think it would change I could go
back and listen to be like okay if it
makes you feel better do it makes you
feel better we were really commenting on
the Nick vile ABC was showing us and not
the Nick vile that we now have known to
like grow and love you know I mean the
only thing I'm gonna object to is that I
understand the Andy and Caitlyn
narratives but I thought again I was I
thought paradise Nick was great a great
chance I've Nick that's the deepest I
hope you told me that on your show I
mean wow
we were moving in a positive direction
until you broke chance that's heart
shouldn't satisfy alpha female Jones M
is fine but we weren't we weren't yeah
it's always saying yeah so you don't
like it when hot girls get dumped
no it appeared like you don't know her
when nothing was wrong just to be The
Bachelor
it appeared that way we know now that
that's not the truth but to the
untrained eye which is what we were
everything was whatever they they didn't
do me any solid that way because they
announced me before I broke up right Jan
which you had it it's just like
subconsciously made it feel like so it
looked like Elan get whispered to on the
beach like hey you wanna be the batter
break up a chat okay yeah definitely not
how it went okay but anyways I'm glad
either way we've we've come full circle
it's great to have you guys on I've
always been very fascinated with with
you women and I thought it might be
interesting I don't know how much you
guys talk about the origin story of how
it all came to be how the morning toast
a very successful podcast
came to be I know and truly I mean you
you guys have the die estar de stuff
Anne's don't cross him I'm I'm envious
I think it's wild you've in a somewhat
healthy wave created a bit of a cultist
following yeah we don't mind the word
cold we're trying to do stigmatize I did
just watch it e true Hollywood story on
nexium and there was a cult leader on
there and he was like describing what a
cult is and I was like oh that's us like
we have charismatic leaders and we make
people feel safe but we don't brand them
or like it's like we're the kind we're
the reason that you get involved in the
cold it's like that you know feeling of
community and steamy vibes is what we
marley but then we don't like turn
around on you and brandy what are steamy
vibes oh so we refer to ourselves for as
the Steen's and obviously just to don't
ask why it's like too long-winded and
this is a long-winded podcast yeah
that's true actually Steen II has come
to mean just like all things that we
feel like we embody and we appreciate
which is just like light hearted
happiness positivity like good music a
margarita on the dance floor like that's
a steamy vibe and so we try and curate
Seanie vibes only and everywhere we love
it they really do follow us around this
vibe since i we have consummated our
friendship I can't tell you that's me
always implies sex unfortunately that is
the word to use in this situation right
no I get up I'll look it up I guess now
we gotta have sex this is turning into
it anyways what a win
I am constantly approached by people who
in fatica Lee will call themselves
toasters not like I listen to the toast
and I'm a I'm a toaster is if you have
indeed brand and I'm just like that is
amazing at me and then proudly to like
an army of people we're like they say it
as if at any moment if listen I'm a fan
of you because they like me but if I got
a Texas that I need to murder you in
this moment I would [ __ ] do it
just so you know yes true yeah like you
exactly you're not following through but
I'm just
I can see the passion in their eyes and
I'm I I'm impressed I'm impressed I
think it's here how did how did it all
start I mean I know girl with no job is
the first time I became aware of your
existence yeah I had been through your
shaming of me yes that was I had been
influencing through college and by the
time I graduate and say yes it is a
full-time job
I love her she embraces it and I started
in college and then by the time I
graduated I was like making enough money
that I didn't find it necessary to get
like an actual job and then after when I
just started trying things out like I
started to DJ like I tried to do things
that would like set me apart make me
money and like further my career into
whatever this landscape was turning into
there was like a general influencing
playbook DJ something else I'll just try
one that sticks the DJ didn't pan out
like in the way that I had hoped that it
would like I am NOT being invited to
Ibiza - you know rage with Paris Hilton
unfortunately but life had different
plans for me and I started a podcast
called girl with a podcast that was
hosted by myself in my apartment and it
was absolutely awful like I could not
believe people like ever listened to it
but I move it along it was about like
whatever I could get my hands on it was
a lot of reality show recaps a lot of
bachelor stuff Real Housewives stuff
like life you know updates with my
husband I was like engaged at the time
it was not good and it has been scrubbed
from the internet so don't even try and
find it but I liked podcasting a lot and
at the same time we had gotten this
opportunity Jackie was working at oath
which is a Verizon company and we had
gotten this opportunity to start our own
brand they basically gave us budget it
was like do whatever you want and we had
always wanted to be morning show host
versus that's with morning [ __ ] did you
ever see the movie The Morning Glory
Morning Glory
yes great movie that really is the
reason why we are sitting here today
we're so inspired by Harrison Ford and
Rachel McAdams and it was just and it
was just watched it not too long ago on
a Delta flight know at home I got I took
an edible that's how close friends
started on my Instagram oh yeah
I'm an honor to be a part of it and I I
was I not I don't think so you sure
you're oh I'll tell check oh but I gotta
add you to I'll double check but I I and
I basically reviewed Morning Glory cause
it's so good it's what I'm Harrison
Ford's best part completely a frittata
for time when he's just like what would
the people in the brief race news men
papers they're reviewing those like
promos for the new show that is so funny
like me and Jackie used to rewatch that
scene over and over and like that movie
really inspired us just like about the
impact of daytime television when you
look at the daytime television landscape
today it's like as a 25 year old
millennial do I feel represented at all
and then look at all these shows I'm
like no I think like the only person
who's even remotely close to like the
Millennial age on daytime television is
Megan McCain but that shows just not
really for me like the view is a
scariest place on earth and no no
nothing against Megan McCain if she's
your voice didn't yeah you're just
saying that's the closest walk like
she's the really the youngest person on
daytime and not everyone wants to wake
up and talk about politics I certainly
don't so sometimes it's just nice to
have like a fun light-hearted that's
what like this teeny vibes are just like
fun like the our listeners are from all
over the world and if you ever threw in
like a hot-button issue like they would
not agree on a single thing like
everyone has totally life different life
experiences but that's what makes a show
fun it's like you don't have to get that
deep yeah there's something for everyone
when you see we're influencing in
college what were you doing um so I was
like building my following on Instagram
I was working with a lot of brands like
going to different events like posting
pictures of yourself know posting like I
was doing blog content like memes um
just anything that would like make me
money grow my audience like further my
my career mmm humor account yeah that's
great and so then you have the Morning
Glory that's such a great it's such a
reference it is it's so good it's
Harrison Ford's best work I couldn't
agree more
Indiana whoo that was fine but his humor
in that is its subtleties yeah it's such
an underrated movie and if you're
watching this thing haven't seen it
Rachel McAdams
of course thermal and then oh yeah
what's his what's his name that guy Jeff
Goldblum yeah he's the bar and then her
love interest
is like the hottest man alive who played
the doctor and that episode of girls
that was a highly unrealistic Patrick
Wilson yes
understated hot guy huh yeah he just
plays like a handsome guy in every movie
and you're like who was that guy he
should be more famous and then he never
gets more handsome respectable not
offensive but like sure I would yeah
yeah okay so then you started the
morning toast you've been a big hit and
then it's you guys are just
we've just been riding the wave of the
morning show that we thought to see in
the world yes so we started just like
live streaming on Facebook actually
which we don't even do now and then
people were asking for it as a podcast
which was an easy transition for us and
now we're predominantly a podcast we
stream live on YouTube so we're just
like wherever the internet trust us
we're there we're about to be on
tick-tock you know no that's very
chocolate that worried me because I find
that maybe like it's I'm done it's cool
but like I'm officially neverold yeah
and I don't think there's anything
really like sadder then like older
people like trying to be on tick-tock
like dancing with their kids that's why
like Matt Lauer yeah Matt Lauer he was
in his daughters tick tock video just
days before Ronan Farrow spoke excerpt
came out and now that videos
mysteriously disappeared shipstation
hard to say super easy to use
I actually dry the internet got a
notification from sip ship station
notification because we had a couple
notified me that ship stations got
covered shipping already import in a sip
ship station I get analytics I get
information I can ship you P USPS FedEx
and UPS so many companies are use it
whether you're a large five fortune 500
company or you're a small out of your
home business it is a wonderful app will
you explain to me
so someone makes an order they take care
of it completely well I have it I have a
fulfillment center yes you have a
fulfillment center so they help with the
process and then but like you just get
um you have immediate information
the order and it's on the app and so
like you can track it and so again if
you're in a business and your customer
like respond I'm trying to get
information on my shipment they're
getting very information it will track
how much you're spending on shipping you
can run historical reports off your
phone it's and it's just very easy to
use and very affordable so like any type
of shipping especially if you have a
small business out of your home I
absolutely recommend it because it's
just it just makes your life so much
easier and shipping is such a big part
of any business especially if it's any
type of e-commerce and if you are
literally shipping it you know sort of
like someone come in your house and
buying it from you it's such a big and
in the end of the year taxes in terms of
getting information what you spent on
shipping and I can't I can't recommend
it enough so take the hassle out of
holiday shipping this year let
shipstation help you handle it all with
ease just use my offer code VI AL to get
a 60 day free trial that's two months
free of no hassle stress free holiday
shipping just visit ship station calm
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in VI AOL that's ship
station comm enter offer code VI al ship
station make ship happen interesting
transition I wasn't expecting to go into
this quite yet but Matt Lauer yeah
obviously has been in the news for
sexual misconduct yet you've been
outspoken about some of the experiences
that you've had with one celebrity Cuba
Gooding jr. mr. jr. not so good it yeah
not so good Inge it honestly it's so
crazy that like people are talking about
it now because this kind of incident
happened to me in high school I'm like
everyone in my high school knew about it
cuz like so many of the kids in my grade
were with me and like it's just been
like a story that I tell people all the
time and nobody has really cared enough
to like make it a big deal until um he
did it to someone else and she just had
like a very normal reaction and called
the police which is like I guess what
you're supposed to do and now it's like
more people are stepping forward and
people are kind of picking up on podcast
episodes or like different radio shows
that I've done where I spoke about it
and it's like I cannot believe like how
big of a story it turned
and to like that's the most press I've
ever gotten and it's honestly not really
what I wanted to be known for um but
yeah I and I actually saw him recently
like what after he the big news story
came out about him and then everyone
started picking up old podcast episodes
of mine I ran into him in the Hamptons
um at a party and he was just like
sitting there and like it was actually
so crazy like it was at the height of of
the press and he seemed completely
unaffected by it he was like surrounded
by a million girls running around a
party he looked pretty drunk it was so
crazy like I I felt shook to like be in
his presence it was like he was
overwhelming oh no it was almost scary I
can only imagine when someone is like so
famous and like has such a bigger like
he's like so wealthy so but like it's
just it is intimidating but like I was
more so like you know it's so crazy I'm
sitting two feet from you and you have
no idea who I am yet you stuck your
finger on my butt in the club ten years
you know no it's true yeah I remember
when it came out and then I remember
reading some of your comments on online
and listen you are an outspoken person
and you you guys both of you that's part
of your charm to kind of say what's on
your mind and you guys will admit
sometimes so yeah my bad you know
sometimes you you can [ __ ] it up but
when your job is talking sure minimum
six hours a week like sometimes
something bad it slips my point I'm only
saying that as as much as you guys have
your dark-haired fans you also have your
your critics and so when that came out I
was reading some stuff and obviously it
wasn't as that day wasn't filled with
overwhelming support yeah a lot of it
was about 5050 it was 5050 I which is in
which seems that's that's a lot of
criticism especially with something
that's so personal right expected like
the Twitter like Twitter's such a dark
place and you could do you know be the
biggest philanthropist humanitarian in
the world and someone on Twitter would
still have something to ask me to say
about you so I didn't really give a lot
of legs to like people on Twitter being
like oh she's lying for money like I
don't care like that's not true and I'm
used to like the negativity on Twitter
what I found to be really shocking was
like the the kind of undertones and a
lot of the media articles written about
me was like so disparaging and a lot of
it was like written by women which was
even more shocking and even the
that they use it's just so heavy-handed
like he's in a suit looking like a
professor glasses like a librarian and
they have like a one candid shot of you
where you're like in the middle of the
video speaking with a double chin like
my nose now III yeah
there's a lot of power in the photos
that publications choose the ones look
at the ones they're using today it looks
like really tired and like sad and
guilty look at his face maybe you want
to feel badly for him those those still
shots yeah I mean again I've I've never
experienced anything like that it's all
been vanity a my end but like you can
totally tell when they're writing a
story by whose side or maybe they're not
even on a side but they're not
necessarily trying to make you look
great yeah and it's just like there's a
million pictures out there of meeting
you're always picture pick you guys will
pick this one where like I'm blinking or
I look smug right all right look you
know like god only knows like but back
to your situation I mean it how did you
get through that I mean in the sense
that like we are in a time where people
are encouraged try to come forward right
you do know and you know you have your
purse now you're outspoken you lead with
humor yeah regardless of what happens
your life a little bit I know about you
you seem to try to you know make light
of what sometimes is a difficult thing
to talk about and that opens you up to
criticism like oh you're you know you're
making jokes and yet how did that make
you feel when you you you come out and
you do this thing and then you have
people and and it seems like even women
questioning you judging you you know
doing all these things I mean that must
have been really tough yeah I don't
really know how it made me feel I was
just it was more like a shock being like
I never thought like I know I get
criticism for a lot of stuff that I
expect to get criticism for like if I
say something that's unpopular or kind
of ignorant like I know when my backlash
is deserved but I was just more shocked
at like the the different angles people
were looking at it from like me trying
to exploit Cuba Gooding jr. for money
like I never spoke to him I don't want
money from him like I would literally
rather die than take a dollar from him
like I was just sharing my experience
because a lot of people were like this
girl's lying and if you watch a video
like it's kind of blurry like no
it's definitely not she's definitely not
lying because a it happened to me and B
just because I've been so outspoken
about it like I in the in the last you
know two years being on the road doing
mean greets like I have a cat
countless people tell me the exact same
thing that happened to them or even more
graphic like he kissed me and I
literally was just walking by him he
grabbed me kissed me some girl was like
he grabbed my vagina like like so many
different stories that's how I know this
girl's not lying so it was it was more
of like a shock factor than anything
else you know yeah I mean well I I just
think it's it's great that you were able
to at least speak your truth and it's
not always easy to do and do you feel
like you know when you tell the story
you've been outspoken it with your
audience that you're you're you're
giving more people like you said whether
it's Cuba Gooding jr. or just some guy
down the street when it's happening out
there to women we still have a culture
where people feel unsafe to come forward
for this very thing and I think when the
person is like a well-known rich
celebrity it makes it even harder nobody
wants to turn on you know an American
Hero snow dogs the guy from the snow
dogs like no one wants to turn on them
so it makes it really much harder I a
friend told me not too long ago and it
really stuck with me and he said in 2019
people don't believe the facts they
believe who they like more yeah it's a
we it's a popularity contest
these days especially with social media
and so sometimes it becomes harder and
harder to come out and say something for
fear of especially to that person where
you know that they might have a
following or supporters and it's just
like I know matter what no matter I
could literally show a video and people
will find ways to discredit it and it
can be and I didn't say it freak for any
reason like I didn't wanna like I didn't
want people to take my side like I just
said it because it's what happened and
I've been talking about it for years you
could add sending the kids I went to
high school with like it was a craziest
night I was like who the [ __ ] just put
their finger on my butt and that's like
there's no motives behind why I said
what I said I only said it cuz it's
[ __ ] true ok yeah yeah I uh I've I've
over the years I've gone on dates with
with people and got to know them and you
they've some of them admitted things
that have happened to me when they were
young and it's
it's sometimes shocking in almost all
these cases and there's been a handful
they didn't tell anyone they just just
kept it quiet and the reason I don't
like running tell the police is like
first of all the time like this was I
don't know how like maybe eight years
ago like times were so different like I
don't know if I necessarily knew what
sexual assault was there like that that
was considered sexual assault like I
only knew about sexual assault like what
I saw on Degrassi you know what I mean
like that's really how I knew she was
different times and I was also a
sixteen-year-old in a club and I wasn't
actually call the police and like
incriminate myself I was more focused on
like I'm gonna get in trouble like I
didn't tell anyone fake ID taken yeah
like everybody get grounded because I'm
in in a club drinking alcohol so like
and and that's kind of what people
fixated on like what kind of degenerate
goes to a club at 16 like sorry I was
cool okay I was cool and I went to clubs
and have a great [ __ ] time and like
that it's just so it's nuts what people
like latch on to you know totally are
you involved in the court proceeding no
I mean I have like that's what I'm
saying like I have no intention with
telling people other than to like say
like it's a skirt robberies go straight
I'm not trying to file charges like I
don't even know what the statute of
limitations are like I don't even know
how I would prove it but I'm just saying
it happened yeah no I mean that's an
interesting point to that I I know
someone who knows him and it's totally
separate than you guys coming on the
show it came up and I was and then my my
friend who's like oh this girl's lying
you know me she's more like when she's
an acquaintance
I'm just anyways I'm not trying to get
into it but like she she only she knows
him or whatever and and I just think it
I can't I'm sure she's friends with them
I don't know her reasoning but I just
said what like I sent her it was when he
got accused again I sent like there's a
bunch of stuff out there my life I'm at
a point of bringing this up is you
coming out and telling your story for
only reason to tell your story is
because of the girl who actually is
putting her face in it and accusing it
I'm sure she's being told she's a liar
by all these other people and I my
response and was like well isn't
I have a friend who this happened to
there's clearly many more I mean listen
I understand that sometimes people can
lie but like in these situations where
you have all these victims speaking up
verse one guy's word remember so for you
to say it I think is a great thing in a
sense that like if your only reason is
to show support
this person says yes yeah so anyways
let's make it lighter you guys are both
married you're both young yes how old
are you I am 26 for the next three weeks
I'm 25
you're 25 so relatively still young
women married we talk a lot about on
this show
especially with questions from Nick
about age and and where he'll play a
role in your perspective I sometimes get
accused of age shaming do you in which
direction about the youth oh the you
this I'm older and so like it's just
more I know it's more like hey listen
when I was this age I did this this and
this and I have a little bit more
perspective now you know in you know
what you do have seven years on us like
I hate when people like you're 25 and
they're 26 like oh when I was well the
rich wasn't there I mean there was a
time I think was been season when when
Olivia was age shaming Emily and they
were the same well you're just young you
didn't really know any better period
sure but at the same time there are you
know exceptions to rules and and just
because you are older doesn't mean you
have perspective or maturity and I guess
what I'm saying is you guys are so damn
accomplished at such a young age you
have like Izzy guys seem like you're
good to go like your lives are set you
got your husband's got your media empire
appreciate you saying that because that
is like the fake image we put forth on
social media so we really appreciate it
so tell me the real mess that is your
life son has a mess just cuz it looks
like something doesn't mean that it is
and that's like the the golden rule of
social media like don't believe what you
see um
but be married is the [ __ ] like overall
I highly recommend you but it is like
hard you know relationships are how to
make it work and it's not like you know
there's another person and weaving two
lives together
three years is in
always easy but generally speaking I
would highly recommend it to anyone it's
like it feels like you can finally just
breathe interesting yeah how long were
you guys dating your respective husbands
before you got engaged / married a long
time we were dating for like four years
through college but I wasn't allowed to
get engaged while I was still in college
so I graduated in May we got engaged in
June my parents didn't let you yeah and
it was also like there were a couple
girls I went to NYU so like there were a
lot of girls who like would walk around
class with an engagement ring and like
it was just kind of weird that I felt
like it was almost like inappropriate
like you just didn't want to be that
girl I didn't wanna be that girl who
makes sense
yeah and what about you uh so I was
dating my now husband for two and a half
years before we got engaged and then we
got married a year later sir were been
together total almost four years do you
got I mean so your husband was he your
own your first love yeah okay when I was
18 in trouble one woman man their
romance excellent person no no I got an
urge like nothing that's nerdy it's cool
you could like if your clothes really
come on podcast we'll say things like
all on backtrack who know cause like I
not that it's like late it's not lame or
anything but there's like oh like the
conversations around Colton hemming a
virgin like I thought that was so rude
like you cannot like Colton for other
reasons but like I think it's kind of
nice it's not actually like [ __ ] a
million girls and carrying all these
kinds of venereal diseases and I thought
like the conversations around like him
being a loser for that we're like really
inappropriate so that's not that's not
what I wanted to like to convey but what
I meant was I didn't set out being like
I'm saving myself for marriage I was 18
when I lost my virginity that's just
Robin I married him do you ever get
worried or something do you ever get the
itch about like what else is out there
so to speak not necessary for sex but
just the temptation of well for Sam's oh
my god um the idea of being naked in
front of someone like makes me want to
die so like I found one person who like
loves me for me and I don't want to get
anything in front of anyone else ever
again like I don't want to go to the
beach so I'm really happy like not ever
having to have sex with anyone um
and Ben is everything like I I find that
um people think like when you get
married like you've never talked to a
man again like you talk to whoever you
want like you can get to know people
have interesting conversations with
people just don't
and [ __ ] them and I'm cool dad that's
works for you yeah very much what about
what about you um so I like dated in
college and stuff but nothing at this
was like my first real serious
relationship and like once we started
dating it was just like we're getting
mad like you just know as opposed to
like when you're always on edge with
someone you feel like you can't be
yourself I feel like I dated not even
dated because they'd be like wouldn't
ever like admit that they dated me you
know we're not exclusive
what do you mean like I was in so many
like we just met a year ago like we were
literally hooking up like I was in
college looking up with someone for one
whole year like it how I mean ever went
on the date like that's crazy
yeah so um that's so cool did you ever
try though
yeah just no cool check okay so I wanted
to be cool for sure but I definitely
tried and then there was one time when I
like put myself out there which was so
hard for me and I got so shut down and
that's when I that was when the year was
up and I finally and I finally moved on
um but no so being married now I mean we
Smet when I was 24 so I feel like I I I
really like to live yeah and I met a lot
of different people and like so many
people like suck so hard and so many
guys just like our [ __ ] because they
think that's how they're supposed to act
you know they don't even mean it they're
just like oh this is what we do yeah but
also they're like loser girls who like
make it make boys think that that's how
they should act and I blame those girls
I'm sorry it's a it's a little bit of
both of yeah I mean it's it's definitely
how guys get raised and how they think
they should act and yes sometimes they
are egged on but by women who like mean
guys who or who or will emasculate them
for not being macho enough or not you
know you know women calling guys [ __ ]
I know happens when t sigma ties the
word [ __ ] yeah we had a whole podcast
old podcast episode about it your diet
I mean basically that he grew up where
the like now I think of the word [ __ ]
and it's like porn like give it that
[ __ ] but but we grew up using the word
[ __ ] as like a very sweet endearing
like maternal term like a childish term
for a mature forever justice in
like vajayjay like see like question
mushy yeah so we were shocked to grow up
and you guys have no brothers right
at least on our podcast very recently
and we're like there's probably some
people out there who have the same
experience like we are aware that this
is so strange the word [ __ ] like has
the ability to be so sweet and like
endearing and I think that porn like
ruined it so we're trying to take back
the [ __ ] okay okay even though like it
hurts coming out like a wedding around a
podcast it's like what is she saying
there's every time you've said it I was
slightly shocking but we used to say
going up and I remember then someone
said it to me like whoa that's like a
really that's like a perverse word like
you shouldn't use it the way that you
are and then after that I was shamed
into into not using it until now well I
mean you guys aren't wrong in a sense
like listen the word was taken and made
into something and that's what it is
so I mean you're probably not going to
change it it's definitely not a vine to
die on for sure but yes we it was it was
totally turned into that but I digress
as young women who are married and
excited about marriage we do get a lot
of questions from people who talk about
the spark losing the spark the
excitement years in the marriage or even
two years in the marriage I loved how
you talked about just because you're
married doesn't mean you can't have fun
have your independence do things but yet
I've so many people seem to equate
getting married to the end yeah like
well I'm just gonna give up on life I'm
my wardrobe is a healthy dose of
sweatpants and t-shirts and stains I
don't need to work out you're not
allowed to talk to anyone else you can't
have friends of the opposite sex now
there's variables and all these things
you know the Devils in the details but
sure but is this a discussion that you
guys had you guys just get lucky with
your husband's like what are you guys
doing cuz inevitable
in five or seven years there will be a
rather regularity to your relationships
and what are you guys doing already to
kind of keep it fun and interesting
other than the fact that you guys are
obviously spunky and fun an intro first
of all I feel like it's also
case-by-case on the type of person that
you marry like some people are really
like scared by the idea of like
regularity and comfort and like I live
correct Alera tea regularity especially
like given the work that I do like I
travel so much and spend so much time
away from home that it makes those
regular moments like so special like I
can't believe anyone would not like this
you know but I guess that's just a
benefit of like having to travel a lot
and being on tour like it makes the
moments at home like that would seem
boring and regular so special and like
unique and I can't get enough of it um
not to say they in order to have a good
marriage you have to spend time away
from home but like it is important to
have like live like I think a lot of
people get married and they lose their
friends and they like think that they
can't talk if you had any guy friends
who were guys like you can never talk to
them again well my best one in the world
Ava's a guide like any actually you look
just like him um so I don't know it's
like important to have your own thing
going on yeah and not be like so afraid
of being comfortable like why is that
bad but being lorded swept a board is so
underrated I feel yeah you think being
bored is underrated okay hold on one
second before we dive into that but I do
want to get back to something you said
in that I think it's yeah there is
definitely a difference between you
don't go out your way to have and like
you don't go out your way to spend time
apart I mean I guess sometimes maybe you
need two girls if you do have time apart
it's nothing to not embrace or have fun
you know whatever your situation is like
in you know even if for if you're not
doing tours you are spending time away
like so your family so your friends like
people are busy you can enjoy missing
someone rather than like you know what
they say about fighting makes the heart
grow stronger or out of sight out of
mind
boredom is underrated I'm not
necessarily disagree I'm curious what
you mean by that we talked a lot about
boredom on the show in the sense that
like we do in my Q&A with questions is
like people data
calling in and people ask me like well
why are you good at asking them and I
just say well almost every question
comes down to ego or boredom
like that's usually the answer to
everyone's dating question it's like
they're either driven by their ego and
trying to do something that their egos
telling them they need to evaluate
ourselves or they're just probably bored
yeah and they're doing it yeah and you
know boredom in the sense that our our
brain actually prefers scientifically
pain to boredom interesting in the sense
that our brain seek stimulation right
pain is a is a type of stimulation yeah
boredom is by definition no stimulation
in the in the scientific sense but yet
you were an advocate Oh boredom way I'm
curious like I just think it's
underappreciated and it feel like when
you have really stressful times it makes
you appreciate the times worth it when
things are quiet and there's nothing on
your mind
so when right so until you have like a
stressful situation you won't appreciate
being bored but once you're over that
hill I think you now you get to
appreciate those quieter moments yeah
you know and especially my husband and I
we like each work and we have busy full
lives so when we are together we just
like appreciate the quietness and just
like the simplicity of being together
that's great but there's definitely a
skill there I'm curious is do you know
how you do that because I think there's
a lot of people and I would include
myself that even in the situation's I
would say oh my god I'm not stressed
about this and this is cool but then
when it happens that I'm anxious you
know anxious because I don't have
anything going on or I feel like
unsettled also especially in this
industry like when you are bored and
like you're not working you're like oh
my god I'm turning irrelevant like I
don't really say I I have that anxiety
too and I so I'm curious as how my like
philosophy and life I feel like so many
times people get so and not that
ambition is a bad thing whatsoever but
people get so eager to be some so much
more than they are when it's like if you
take a step back and look at your life
like you're doing great like be happy
with what you have because you might not
have it forever
right so I feel like when it comes to
career and I've always had that
mentality where it's like everyone wants
more and more more what am I gonna be
doing next like I love what I'm doing
now I want to enjoy what I'm doing now
because I there's no guarantee I'm gonna
be able to do it forever
that's a brilliant way of thinking but
you are unique in that I know I know
that I'm unique and I always have fun
it's like a movie it's like the movie
the greatest showmen have you seen it
the greatest shape in inaudible film but
he gets carried away with himself a
little bit when it's like what you had
at that time like he wants to go on tour
with Jenny Lind and he mortgages his
house and it's a beautiful home and it's
like you had a beautiful home and a
wonderful show like can't that be enough
summer I'm you know I needed to capture
the rich people right but yeah exactly
he didn't like that society you know
what didn't think too fond of him like
we're disgraced Queens over here you
love it I love it you just have to
sometimes know where you are in like
appreciate it and be happy with it I
think that's a great I I said that
knowing that it's not a strength of mine
I'm just like it sounds so great if you
ever have a problem you just got to go
to Jackie she's the wisest person on
planet earth it's very level-headedness
of you and and I think it's set in a
time where we it's it's were our season
I'm particularly bad at it I think it's
my personality but I think your society
in general is like we're in Grain too we
have again as part of is we have so much
access to see what we're not doing other
people's access to compare ourselves to
literally anything we want to compare
ourselves to so to feel settled and
insecure with what you're doing is
becoming a harder harder thing to
typically agree and then also on the
flip side you border on complacency a
little bit so I think that's something
like that would be what I have to you
know work on sometimes but everyone has
life is the balance how are you guys
similar and different because I get I
see obviously some similarities in some
differences and it seems as though you
guys your whole family
complement each other quite well it's
really true well we're different because
um I'm dumb and Jackie's smart like it's
so crazy like we run a business together
and like I'll come up with an idea I'm
like Jackie we should do this and
Jackie's like well here's why we
shouldn't do it and she's like predicts
the future and she's never been wrong
and it's so crazy it's actually really
nice and I'm sure it's a lot of pressure
for you but like it's nice to run a
business and like be related to someone
who just can she's like Raven Baxter
like she can see the future and she
knows what's right for us and she knows
like when to stand her ground and when
when to give in like it's so crazy like
I attribute all the success of the show
just to Jackie's like level-headedness
and ability to like literally see the
future I can't say I'm crazy you're
clearly coming rings
milites the energy talents to the show
well yeah she's just kind of keeping a
leash on you so to speak she's holding
in the brilliance that's great business
goes we always say like Claudia's like
this creative like energetic like I
don't know left-brain right-brain but
she's one of the brains and I'm like HR
and standards and I'm like this is what
we have to do by quarterly end of your
earnings and we will get where we need
to go in order for you to continue
I'm compliant your thing yeah yeah but
like to people who don't know us very
well we are like twins you know we talk
the same we love the same things we have
the same life experience yeah we're so
similar but then once you get to know us
you realize like how different we are
but at the end of the day like we're all
similar jockeys are refined like lady
and I'm a beast so did you ever watch
Desperate Housewives
I've seen it so like Jackie's a Bree van
de Kamp and I'm much more of Lynette are
you unfortunately I love all your
references are like mm yeah well 2000
was the golden age of television it was
and Desperate Housewives was on too soon
this is a bit outdated when this is
gonna go into drop but this morning
Jennifer Aniston join Instagram
Instagram which one of you hates friends
Jackie and you love friend yes I have
taste yes I'm uh
I don't hate friends by any stretch but
it's not amazing about friends my
full-time job is defending friends and
it's like sorry like you don't know true
comedy and I'm seriously I'm not gonna
do it it's amazing if you want me to
walk off think it's amazing w I'm just
more of a Seinfeld guy oh god have you
seen that tweet that's been going around
about the person who wants to win the
lottery so that they can buy the rights
to friends and take out all the life
tracks and put it back up so people can
see how unfunny it is that's my kind of
guy that's my kind of guy I appreciate
the yes I like whether he's right or
wrong I like the thought process it's
not even that I want to just take out
the laugh track so that maybe I have a
chance at enjoying it because I find
that laughing I know it's not a track
it's a live audience or they like beat
you to clapping that's truly it's like
this is how I feel about having
conversations about Taylor Swift like
I'm not gonna sit
defend my Taylor Swift is the greatest
artists business woman alive like we're
huge Taylor Swift I find myself in these
precarious situations all the time like
having to defend my love of friends
having to defend my love of Taylor
stripes and like honestly I'm just not
gonna do it anymore I'm at a place in my
life where I just don't feel like I have
to defend myself I'm just not going to
it's exhausting like when something so
personal to you like friends is so
personal to me like I feel like I have
such bad anxiety I put friends on like
it calms me down Taylor Swift is like my
icon like I just don't feel the need to
defend my choices anymore I got my
[ __ ] choice whoo whoo whoo what
friends character yeah oh I feel like
this is kind of controversial I'm so
glad we like changing the tide I feel
like I'm now she's had first she sour I
think we kind of ready like a Ross I'm
Ross okay let me tell you why and
actually I feel like you'll actually I
don't love that I'm Ross but I've
definitely Ross so it's like when
someone says they love Ross there's two
reactions like yeah or like [ __ ] yeah
like you're a part of the club and when
someone's like I love Claudia either
they're like she sucks or they're like
oh man she's a [ __ ] tits I love her I
guess I guess I thought people have
responded to me it's not like I'm not
Joey which is like oh my god he's just
so not offensive and funny it's just
like okay he's a one-trick pony who put
spaghetti in the carpet but there's like
a slow burn to Ross and a charm that's
and it's like you it sneaks up on you
why I feel like I'm a Ross he's so
earnest is because when people like
don't like Ross they refuse to see like
the real charm in him but if you can
watch friends as completely like you
know unbiased and look at David
Schwimmer like you will see that David
trimmer is the best actor on that show
Ross is the most complex complex
character and like he really makes you
laugh the most and even though he's just
not obviously funny like a Phoebe or
Joey he's probably one of the funniest
characters and that's how I feel about
me it's like I think I'm amazing but
like it just takes like a special eye to
see how amazing I am do you not I mean I
mean that subtle I think it's something
yeah yeah but yeah I'm Ross who are you
I'm just gonna ask you guys who am i oh
I think you're kind of you're definitely
Rachel okay okay look pretty oh thanks
pretty like everyone you know like
well-liked I see a little Phoebe I'll be
on
well let's complement yes it's a huge
[ __ ] uh I was gonna say I was in the
same Monica oh my god my sister only in
this podcast only not okay clearly you
have strong pains but mama she [ __ ]
sucks
if she had died in the first episode the
show that's my only critique I just
Monica is the taskmaster and you just
described someone who kind of keeps the
family in lines maybe that's not
necessarily Rachel Rachel has to like
someone has to convince her to cut her
credit card shock he's definitely like
the you know the color-coded binder kind
of gal yeah someone does have to
convince me to cut my credit card yeah
you know you're actually you're a hybrid
you are a fusion of Rachel and Monica
now that I think about it I will take it
because I don't know what it means all
the good parts of each like it from
Monica like you're not not fun you're
actually very fun Monica's not fun and
with Rachel you're not stupid
like rachel is makes the worst decisions
understand a Carrie Bradshaw a teri
hatcher Desperate Housewives
Susan MoMA Serena fender what's in the
moment yeah I have no idea you're
talking about you say with passion
passion is very convincing we've come to
realize that a lot of popular shows
especially ones we liked as a kid if you
go back and watch as an adult the main
characters actually the worst character
quite a treasure it's very difficult to
watch they have terrible decision-making
skills and you're shocked that you ever
liked the show as a kid because like you
watch and I was an adult seeing like how
[ __ ] stupid they are you know yeah
but that's what's relatable about life I
wouldn't make dumb decisions like that
like carry Freight out with hindsight
that's true you wouldn't you wouldn't
make dumb decisions like that you feel
like I feel like okay fine you know you
totally got me there I'm sorry yeah I
take it as we all have like there were
enough people watching it's a scripted
we're reading their water to shame you
can say that about me the reality TV
reject not rejects we all are
reality TV I said I say that as a I
embrace with pride what we're yeah the
reality TV star I have more I have a
heart I don't like
I'd rather be called a rally TV reject
in a reality TV star okay
there's simply a stigma with with the
phrase reality TV star it's being
destabilized yes we are we are coming
you technically have a same job title as
Kim Kardashian yeah well you know some
of us rejects have dated real
celebrities and that's you know Mike
Jonathan well he's he's out of control
someone's got to chase him he is nuts
he's no wait what do you mean he asked
Annie Palmer live on The Today Show yes
why way MA and he was is really I
thought he was dating no apparently it's
over because he said he made a mistake
in being so public about it so then he
went on to publicly ask ow keke palmer
on her show at work you say yes no no
she was like cringing so hard so she was
but she's a class act like she would
never yeah
really feeling himself yeah you know I
tried to walk and now they're running
they're sprinting they're going not
people give credit to Wells and Sarah
for being like the first couple to kind
of you know lean into like traditional
celebrity um but people really don't
give proper credit because you were out
here you know dating January Jones
before anyone else and now rachel bilson
like you you're really doing you're
doing the Lord's work and you're not
getting any credit for and you're great
I'm private about surprising me in my
daily life so I don't really comment on
that I like Mike he seems that [ __ ]
needs itself like you put a picture on
your Instagram story of like a girl
wearing a white dress and then it was
like wait Rolston was wearing that white
dress so like me things like you're
dating Rachel Wilson sometimes you can
just go to dinner with someone who's
your friend and you have a lot of
friends as you spoke about as women who
are women a hundred percent that's why
you're so woke so we don't really know
what to think which is why we came here
yeah to find the T I do enjoy keeping
people on their on their toes retells
after yes and we Claudia yeah you are
also are your stand-up comedian yeah
that yes you're a stand-up comedian yep
big time ah Rochelle also cinema
community I I have a dream one day of
doing it not because I think I'll be
good King once said wanna yeah me and
Martin
how did you start that I mean again
that's really cool
there is a your 25.4 [ __ ] I don't know
25 accomplished comedian you're selling
out theaters it's a huge privilege one
I'm only afforded because of the
internet like I started whatever the
reason whatever the reason I just wanted
to do comedy and I don't think I was
brave enough to do it you know at an
open mic so it's always something that's
been on on my mind but when I was like I
said I've just been trying different
things with the internet and whatever
sticks great whatever doesn't great um
and so I just launched a live show at
Caroline's like 18 months ago in New
York and I just like I'm gonna do this
yeah and they wanted to have me just
because we had a popular podcast so I
was really grateful for the opportunity
and I was like so nervous about selling
tickets I launched two shows and I'm
when I was on a plane taking off and I
was freaking out because it was like 959
959 410 I mean the time I was 10 o'clock
I was like in the middle of taking off
so by the time I got Wi-Fi like 10
minutes later I was having a pan I was
like I'm anxiety and the plane and it
sold out and I was like oh my god so
then I was like oh [ __ ] like it sold out
like now I have to like do and I do you
and Shepherd understand it before never
and I think oh my god you sold out a
90-minute show winning totally well with
you well because my first hurdle was the
selling and then I'm like well if it
sells I'll figure it out and then it's
sold and I was like I'll [ __ ] like I got
to figure it out um so I started work
with a comedy coach and to be honest
like you can't you can't like learn
comedy like you just got to [ __ ] do
it but it's hard to do it in front of us
all that audience like most people have
the practice in front of like an open
mic a couple people five minutes here
for a minute Sarah um so I ended up
doing six shows at Caroline's and each
one was better than the next I'm better
no matter better and it was 280 people
so it's like a pretty big audience to be
practicing in front of but like you said
our fans are very supportive and they
were loving and they were just happy to
be there and and I was really grateful
for like the the mattress pad like they
they weren't too tough sure um and then
we just started adding more shows and it
turned into like an 18-month tour that
I'm still on and we started doing comedy
clubs and I'm only doing theatres and
it's everything like I wish that I had
done it sooner I wish it like I hadn't
been so afraid because like the amount
of progress I feel like I've made in my
own abilities in the last 18
like I'm impressed with myself that I'm
like wow if I actually started this five
months ago like maybe I have a [ __ ]
Netflix special or something you know I
mean five years ago I think about that a
lot and I often don't take my own advice
in that department my life has been a
series of finally doing things only to
realize it was never as hard as I made
it out to be
yeah I think generally in life that's
the case is as hard as you make it out
it's the hardest
I'm not Nestle talking about stand-up
specifically but like taking risks you
know it might just be like moving
downtown whatever it is moving to a
different City
you know people so much I don't think I
can really say move it seems so harmless
when you really break it down it's not
that hard yeah I mean it's slightly
different then you'll do anybody's you
should have done it sooner value and
facing your fears and sometimes it
doesn't work out the way that you wanted
to but sometimes it does no that's a I I
think it's really neat and I and I like
for me again the biggest takeaway is
whether it's comedy or not but in terms
of just being not afraid to fail because
it could have not worked out though you
could have not sold out you could have
sold out terrible job you literally
didn't know probably did do a terrible
job now if I watched it I would like die
of shame well you probably have gotten
better I think it sounds like you were
did you have other open for you or you
know oh my god
so I tried telling straight stand-up the
first time yeah the first time so
basically what I did to kind of get to
the place that I'm at now is like I put
together more of like a variety show
where I would do thirty minutes of
stand-up a lot if you know uh people at
home and then I would like you know play
games that were like it was like I'd
never have I ever but he was still
standing but there was more structure to
it cuz I didn't know like have a
transition and to just like telling a
story by the time I almost got arrested
at the Syracuse Airport you know and
then I would have like guess like
Caitlyn from The Bachelorette came on
and I slowly started to in like a QA and
then I check out the Q&A and I made the
30 minutes a little bit longer then I
took out the the games made the 30
minutes 60 minutes took out the
interview and then then it was 90
minutes on its own and so once I started
dropping those kind of crutches like I
felt so good like and then I almost felt
stupid for ever having done it I'm like
I'm like embarrassed so I used to do it
but that's how I got to the place I
don't even I don't even know how people
and like I can't even ever imagine going
on another tour because like all my
jokes are in listen
like all my stories like I have to like
to live 30 more years before I can ever
write in another show you know still
cool I think it's really neat and it's
also fine that you did improve because
like you can't I think about our podcast
yep okay I think it was pretty good when
it started but I also look back and be
like oh yeah that's better now you know
new ones yeah I don't would be weird if
you didn't
and so like sometimes it's just like
also and then it goes fast you're like
well if if if there were things like
well if I could just be there if I could
just be done people don't want to go
through the journey they don't wanna the
key
they don't wanna put in the hard work we
don't want to embrace it because that's
part of the charm of look you don't
appreciate it and you don't look back
and then if you felt like you weren't
getting better then you'd almost feel
like in business literally the mantra is
if you're not growing you're dying if
you're not getting bigger
like staying the same in business is
death yeah and that's kind of the same
in life if you have a show and it's just
kind of stale and not different and not
improving slowly over time they're
probably with your audience isn't
noticing a definitive change they went
back and listened then it would be kind
of obvious well that's like our mantra
here at the morning toast it's like
there's so much value and growth and I
feel like in like today is kind of like
cancel culture people don't place any
value on the fact that like you can grow
up and like you can be different you're
so quick to like hate somebody because
of something they said ten years ago
when it's like that it's actually very
possible that they don't feel that way
anymore and it's like this is what I
said the other day on the podcast is I
was just re watching the first season of
Entourage and in the episode they say
the r-word on like every other line and
and no one's you know out here canceling
them because it was very much a
different time and I don't think there's
enough acknowledgment to that and the
fact that like now today like HP I
wouldn't really never make a show where
every other word is the R word so I
think that it's okay to grow up and
understand that like as long as you're
evolving I thought sometimes people are
afraid of the word ignorant yeah in a
sense that if you admit that you're
ignorant then all of sudden you have the
Scarlet Letter but sometimes you can say
listen I'm Alan I probably don't know as
much as I do I am ignorant but I do want
to learn
and sometimes I was ignorant I have
learned and I have liked but you got a
I'm still learning always room for
growth yeah it's like embarrassing like
how like ignorant I think I used to be
and I'm still very much embarrassing in
my ignorance but I'm getting a lot
better
we've I know I have been too but like
yes you can acknowledge it you were but
you're still yeah again sometimes our
people are afraid that they have been or
were or can be ignorant but like that's
kind of the first step I don't know
before I let you ladies go we like to
play a game here called do you know me
okay it's a fun little game you can find
on Amazon it's a it's a kind of a party
game but I like it
because I think fun conversations come
from simple questions and so we're Sean
and I are and try to guess who knows you
to better it's real simple
I'm going to read a question I'm going
to insert both your names
we're so and I will guess if you have or
haven't kind of thing there are random
questions and then feel free to
elaborate if you would like ready yep
kicking off do you know me with Claudia
and Jackie has Claudia and or Jackie
kissed someone
in the last 24 hours they are traveling
they're out of town I don't know maybe
they're with their husbands wait we
gotta answer your answer for us i we
first guess then you will let us know
well I don't if they didn't think I
don't think they've cheated on their
husbands you don't admit to it so let's
just assume that would be great for my I
would tell you I do think maybe they are
very affectionate yeah on the on the
cheek some sort of kiss so I'm gonna say
yes they have but it's been with the
each other in a very sister like not
weird porno sorta way you're half-right
because I will like could make out with
my sisters like there's no I can't
there's no such ting
to close like a shower together like I
don't care but Jackie is like a freak
don't touch me she doesn't like to be
hugged you like really I like my space
yet don't get up in my face I don't like
people like Oh get the [ __ ] out of my
face hope um that's an iconic line from
the hit show Vanderpump rules
[Laughter]
personally I definitely have not kissed
anyone in the last 24 hours I have I
think they kissed Lauren Elizabeth the
other night and maybe work one okay
I just love kissing like it was also
more than 24 hours ago though oh that's
true but I didn't leave kiss Margo
where's to be the same bad so yeah what
were you gonna say I was gonna say no so
you're both half right right together
you are right one zero and zero zero is
the score has Claudia or Jackie ever
pissed their pants hells yeah
hells yeah if you're getting in club's
age 16 you're pissed why do I feel like
and I have apologized so if I'm being
offensive that I feel more confident
that Claudia's pissed her pants than
Jackie well that's so shocking I feel
like if Jackie had to piss her pass even
six-year-old Jackie would have liked
what would well obviously everyone's pee
their pants like when their child we're
talking post potty training yes post
potty trained well I appreciate the
offensive you know inference you just
made but now I actually not peed myself
that as an adult I don't say Lee oh
sorry yes I did I was at a wedding in
Brooklyn and I didn't have to she's like
two weeks ago and I I didn't have to pee
when I left the wedding but by the time
I got back into the city it was like a
30 45 minute drive we get to Ben's
apartment this was a couple years ago
I'm like in my gown and I'm wearing
Spanx and Ben doesn't have a key so we
are standing in his hallway when I had
to pay myself
oh that's heat in your space in front of
your husband yeah yeah I've definitely
peed my pants
post potty training it's a familiar
feeling I can't recall like when
specifically but it doesn't sound
foreign yeah okay I thought for sure I
hadn't I was even surprised everyone
yeah it's been really hit you yeah
memory
our god I tried to block it out you know
I was a bit of a bed wetter
eight or nine and seven eight or nine
and since then I've been pretty solid
but pretty solid there was a time I was
rollerskating I know I roller skate now
but when I was a kid I was having so
much fun I just like it's you really
shouldn't be peeing your pants and you
just whip it out and like pee up on a
building or something like as a girl you
can't just like pull your pants down and
squat over the road you know it's hard
at a roller skating rink yeah it was
quite easy when I'm in the hallway
outside Ben's apartment like there would
have been the same option yeah yeah but
like if I had a dick I would have like
went outside and like been on a corner
of the window something like there was
there's no options for a girl it's like
pants or toilet you know dudes it's like
in a bottle or something we are blessed
yeah okay yep does Claudia are Jackie
know which element na is on the periodic
table no I don't that's for sure
I think they do sodium sodium NaCl
assault smart [ __ ] did you know that it
I was gonna guess salt but sodium I was
a physics major for the reward of my
time in college and then I transferred
to be a communications manager phys a
major once I like this is why I love do
you know me Wow
physics major yep your math and science
check yeah well not really any more but
I can't impress him Claud thank you
haven't gotten wrong who would have
known I can't believe I knew that like I
know nothing didn't even hesitate
yeah like please I'm just thinking back
to miss Brooke up pointing at that
periodic table chart of elements I was
really impactful like Breaking Bad
touched you the second time I spoke
about miss Brock hood this week I'm
loved Breaking Bad has Claudia and
Jackie or Jackie ever won more than life
options here $1,000 in Las Vegas but I
feel like your heart just looks super
smug and crossed her arms personal
subjects for one I think
like that's the look she gave I think at
one time she's won more than a thousand
but she's lost more than she's won
overall she's had a big loss I did have
a very big loss in the ritz-carlton in
Puerto Rico it was very tough tough
tough trip for me man we could not get
out of that hole and she's kind of gave
herself away we kept going back every
night just like hoping and you know it
was really tough because at midnight and
this hotel I'm in the casino they would
give out grilled cheeses and they were
so good like they were the perfect
grilled cheese like really smart white
bread American cheese so we used to just
sit around like waiting for the grilled
cheese we just like had to gamble and we
got ourselves into like a huge like
really like and this was you know back
before we were both like if I really
financially like independent and it was
it was really bad what are we talking it
was a lot and I have had you know very
low lows but I had some high [ __ ]
highs and I love winning I have one way
more than a thousand dollars and I just
can't get enough I'm a card counter the
card shark and you're smart you're
acting like you're not smart no actually
I can't count cards like I'm actually
not that smart I just love gambling I
love the thrill I love the environment
of a casino I love the free drinks I
love the camaraderie at a blackjack
table like I just I love gambling so
much like I'm getting the itch right now
you know like we gotta drive to Las
Vegas that's that's also ironically
enough how many people talk about not
trying to get back with ex-boyfriends I
guess gambling is my life ya know or
just like the bad bets one more time
he's gonna be the person I you know what
in gambling like the odds they're not
crazy so like it actually might like
your ex-boyfriend likes just one person
and one chance where it's like there's
many cards that would situate your
situation but I'm the polar opposite I
do not you're risk-averse yeah thanks
how this works right brain yeah also I
sound like the most boring [ __ ] on the
planet like she's such a stick up her
ass but she doesn't she's so fun she
over on Saturdays she needed an IV yeah
and so that's like what people want to
say about me and that's like the worst
thing so true totally fine count your
blessings um no but I and this is
awkward because now we're playing a game
but I really just don't like games and
so annoying like I live to play board
games I feel about this one I'm enjoying
it so far
honestly gently codenames oh that was a
good one
the board game code names the reason I
don't like games is because I don't like
to get involved but when I do I get
really competitive and I'm so invested
that it just takes a lot out of me and
so with gambling I actually don't mind
it but if I'm gonna lose a couple
hundred dollars I'd rather spend it
I just love to shop so I would rather if
you're shopping gambling like I will go
shopping I just I don't mind to lose the
money I just want it to go to something
tangible that makes sense to me I mean
you know what and the drinks I know they
give you free drinks at the casino but
they're disgusting I'd rather pay for a
proper martini they're all sorry they're
also not right there also numbering I I
gambled is a form of entertainment in
the sense that I I'll take out a couple
thousand dollars and the I or a thousand
podcast when we gamble I take out a
hundred dollars I play like fifteen
hours have time and it's like an
activity but over the course of a
weekend if I go to Vegas I mean oh
that's what you're preaching acquire
Nick we gotta take a trip
no but I that I in my mind that's money
I'm going to lose as if I'm going to a
show your money for a good time if I win
great if I don't go to the ATM and take
out more money yeah you know like I
basically budgeted out of the course of
a few days ATM fees are a [ __ ] yeah so
I have some confirm make sense yeah
you're paying for the experiment second
activity said go into the club getting a
table yeah final question yeah but what
if you go gamble and then go to the club
it's like mmm like you're not good
enough table know you guys don't buy
bottles excuse me about the bottle Queen
I live for a bottle I don't know the
biggest bottle at the front table like
like in the hook-up oh that's a
different question you're not buying the
body just went to Vegas for my birthday
and we it was it was really hooked up
except we really wanted to see Diplo @xs
and they don't do hookups but I bought
it anyway because it was like everyone
wants to Diplo and then I just do like
if I didn't if I took them to one of the
free places everyone would be like who
was rude to who and then the people
would like escape and run to Diplo and
I'm like like a dictator when I come
my birthday and like no one's allowed to
leave before its exam so I got it I got
the biggest best tape it was worth every
pie what a paid double we were there and
the club was the eternal lights on
they're sweeping they're sweeping of
confetti I'm like where's Diplo Wow I
kind of wanted to be there but final
question has Claudia or Jackie ever
bought followers for a social media
account Jackie has not I think
claudia has a long time ago when she was
figuring out the whole social media game
she now is ashamed of it she wish she
never did it but it did happen at one
point agree you know when I were big
tags for Lakers well no I bought 500
followers hacked 50 friends
I bought 500 followers when I started a
girl's in her job I had 500 and I wanted
a thousand because back in the day like
the three figures versus the four
figures was like a big deal um I bought
500 followers and then slowly like they
were janky because slowly over time like
they they started disappearing I left
you I got back to 500 yeah so is a huge
mistake one in which I don't endorse cuz
it doesn't work it is pretty pricey -
yeah I don't play followers but I'm
really tempted to like even like right
now after the show I might go buy
something yeah because I think so many
people buy followers brands as much as
they can see your engagement I have the
engagement of someone who has double the
amount of followers that I have I can
buy all those followers and then get
paid like double by brands I mean
obviously not now when I'm expelling on
my whole plan right and now that I'm
saying this I probably won't do it cuz
the tools it's really [ __ ] but they
really don't I see so many premium
influencers who have a million followers
who get the same amount of likes that I
do I just have really high engagement
because if it were toast you're strong
over here we're actually experts and
there are so many influencers who like
weed and we're not dog talking about
like the fit T model girls it's people
who you know who have such low
engagement have so many followers get
huge brand collaborations huge brand
deals and I would say over 50% of their
following is manipulated or purchased or
their followers are from so long ago
that they're not active anymore and
they're just at the bottom of their
algorithm so maybe at no point did they
actually buy followers but they don't
have a good engagement rate and I can
at that same rate if I just bought some
followers but now you would all now yeah
but so can you just follow me yeah sure
go with nun job Jackie Oh problems no
like please talk me out of it because
I'm about to go buy something you should
do she's not going to because I think
engagement rate is way more I mean I all
like I literally as you guys know have
natural habits I'm part of like we do a
lot of marketing I literally purchase
software to look at this fine micro
influencers and as a business owner
looking for people to endorse my brand I
only care about engagement rate I might
actually pay attention to the overall
following I mean I look at it as a
baseline and then I double Xin the
details because you're in influencer so
you know that like these huge
corporations who have like yes 90 year
old white dudes run yeah it's like it's
so crazy and if I'm if I ever do a
campaign I always look at the hash check
to see like who else is running the
campaign and it's shocking how like poor
poorly chosen the poorly researched
these influencers are yeah also we work
with micro influencers the engagement
rate is always higher because of the
ratio but when you have a million
followers that expected engagement rate
it's like two percent like I can get
there guys yeah
let's don't do it no don't I won't
because now everyone knows like not
would be humiliating and then all the
brands would know like if you bump up
like 10,000 because of this podcast we
don't want people to assume that you
bought that's true that's true I'll wait
till after this and then ID credits like
all of your future accomplishments right
it's like when you buy one fake handbag
it ruins your whole collection your
collection looks fake if you carry
around one fake like I feel like a just
admit about the 500 followers like now
everyone thinks my brand is built on
like lies it is but no well you're
honest and vulnerable and that's why
you're relatable and lovely I know you
guys ladies you have to go before we do
your I'm just gonna toasters essential
oils code toasters every time I go on
their show there's a code toasters the
essential I'll I think I'm your number
one customer except she's never paid
right I have some more you've more than
earned it the
code toasters I think the discount is
quite I think it's 20% right it's higher
than that I think it's your favorite the
highest go off of whatever is in my in
my drawer I like them all honestly I
like a little eucalyptus peppermint
situation well Nick is looking that up I
just want to remind you guys tickets to
my tour are available at girl with no
job comm I'm hitting up you know the
west coast we got San Diego San
Francisco we got New York we got
Englewood we just announced two new
shows in Tarrytown in Verona today I
were hitting up on Theriot it's gonna be
really good time so Atlantic City gotta
come throw tickets available up girl no
job no home it's been a 90-minute show
everyone the reviews are in and I think
they're good so you should come do you
want to contribute to me not buying
followers please follow me at Jackie O
problems is all I ask I really quite
like your handle the did you I mean it
was it like an homage to Jackie O yes
well my name is Jackie O so I've always
been Jackie O but it was I made it
during the era of like white girl
problems and everyone had Elise problems
like I'm I have girl problem I was like
I have Jackie O problems cuz they were
all like specific me alone is worth the
follow yeah thank you I actually like do
you want to drop the problems but I
don't think you don't I think Jackie I
was so much sleeker but I don't know
anyone who can help me I'm s - that's
someone who might take themselves very
seriously Jackie Oh proms is like that's
true okay it's not like cheesy no I
think you should stick with it you know
it's a no ping homage to your history
you know and how you got here that's how
I got here I'm built on problems yeah
toasters it's 35% it's the ever given
out I'm gonna activate it for this
episode you guys have been great and
that you're it's the release one that
you sleep with constantly oh she doesn't
pay attention she just uses it which is
fine yeah no I just I like what I have I
don't know what it is NH oils calm love
it ladies thanks so much for coming on
always best of luck in all your
endeavors you guys obviously if you're
not listening in filing them toasters
you guys are not in multiple times the
morning go see Claudia stand up follow
Jackie on Instagram it's been a lot of
fun we'll have to do it again
as always guys don't forget to rate 5
stars on iTunes
send us your comments well you don't
really have to send us your comment so
I'll probably ignore them from my own
mental health but hey we do it for you
[ __ ] you've given us a plug on social
media until next time have a great week
see you Monday
[Music]